we are with Chief curator at the world
Chef Chess Hall of Fame Shannon Bailey
Shannon welcome to the show tell us a
bit about your work with the workshops
Hall of Fame sure well thank you for
having
me we are actually on our 11th year and
I've been the chief curator since it
opened um so it's been a really
wonderful time to celebrate you know the
last couple of years of everything that
we've done last year we had a big
exhibition
um called mine art experience it looked
at all 50 shows 50 that we have done
that's impressive so he opened up in St
Louis and now we've got this incredible
Bobby Fischer Boris basket show up now
tell us about that because it was just
impressive when I went there and visited
thank you um it's the largest exhibition
we've ever done it's got over 500
artifacts
it is looking because we're celebrating
the 50th anniversary of Bobby winning
the World Chess Championship so it
really looks at not only the match but
the whole origin of Bobby and Boris and
the kind of influence that that match
had so we look at everything from when
they were little kids
we dedicate an entire floor just to the
match and then we look at things like
what happened afterwards it's really
great and you're looking at or a replica
of the table there's only two of those
in existence the the real one is in
Iceland I don't think they'll ever let
that go out we were lucky enough to get
one it was really fun kind of recreating
that stage and we really wanted to get a
whole feel of like 1972
[Music]
um it goes you know we're looking at the
games we're looking at all the details
but we're looking at like um how like
the connection that Bobby and Boris had
that they were friends not enemies you
know what did the match mean politically
why was it in Iceland you know it was
really kind of a global event and how
was it received by The Spectators coming
in visiting great um you know you know
we're always excited about the shows
that we do but it means so much to us
especially when the chess players enjoy
the show and I've heard some really
great feedback oh absolutely it's just
amazing and what was your favorite part
putting this together oh my God I loved
this show so much so you know my
background is art history museum in
history and I loved just doing all the
research and research about every detail
I I loved that we had that we took over
the entire museum for the first time
that it wasn't kind of confining us to a
smaller space though we could have done
a show three times the size of what is
over there so you know we'll have a
chance to revisit some of those but I
loved working with you know we worked
with John Donaldson who's doing a
lecture next Tuesday about some of his
research on Fisher he helped us a lot
with the show just kind of reaching out
to people reaching out to the people in
Iceland that were involved with the
match in 72. there's just a lot of
support for him and people can come and
watch that lecture actually yes and
it'll be streaming you can see it on
YouTube as well but we love John
Donaldson he's so great and he is such a
good friend to all of us and you know he
just knows everything about Chess so we
always go to him if we if we need a
detail and we're so happy to bring him
back and let him talk about some of his
research about Bobby Yasser you know
John quite well he was the best man at
my wedding walking chess encyclopedia I
want to say John is and he did these two
volume books on Bobby Fischer great
great research and assisted you on the
on the artifacts I want to say for uh
the the Fisher match I just wanted to
say Shannon first of all I just love all
the work that you guys at the World
Chess Hall of Fame do all of the
inductees a very very special ceremony
just took pay took place uh heartfelt
speeches by Eugenia Torre and uh Jim
Tarzan but for me hey I gotta ask
everybody wants to know burning boards
when do we come back I think I loved it
the first go-around I loved everything
that happened
to tell everybody what burning boards
was about and how what can we do to
encourage it to come back
um I'm working on it oh yes so burning
boards is a kind of artistic experience
created by the artist Glen kaino we did
a show a couple years ago curated by
Larry list that was about Cajun kaino so
there's some great you know obviously
chess and some music and some sculpture
and um it is you play chess with burning
candles yes and uh it was an elegant
event it was so beautiful I participated
in the one here in St Louis and then a
couple months later I did one at
Brandeis University with college
students it was completely different
experience but um you know so incredible
both times and it has always been a
favorite and I'm trying to think because
everything's blending together since
I've been here since day one but it was
like eight or nine years ago I think
right and it is still completely talked
about and we definitely have to do it
again yeah just I just wanted to know
that it's on the back burner and and
things
all I can say Shannon is it's great to
see what has happened at the World Chess
how Hall of Fame how it's developed and
again just speaking on behalf of my
colleagues the induction ceremonies and
you know the crowning of their careers
it's very special thank you for
everything that you and your staff do
it's great just keep up all the good
work and there's also a music series
happening tonight yeah so we have great
great music events at the hall of fame
we have a great one this evening and
it's looking at some kind of like
highlights of Opera and Broadway we kind
of hit every genre of music and then
after the Fishers basket show closes one
of the new shows we're doing is about
Chess and music and we're also doing one
about trust and literature Emily's
curating that one I'm doing chess and
music with Bradley Bailey and then we're
looking at T.S Eliot and chess so we're
really excited about those shows and
those will open up those will be the
summer shows Shannon thank you very much
for uh what you're doing probably we
will be there tonight yes yes I'm
looking forward your tickets guys yes
for sure to have this unique experience
right absolutely thank you again Shannon
very